i look like avril lavigne in the early
2000s even she doesn't want to look like
this anymore
i didn't know how this looked until i
put the lights on and i want you all to
know that this is not dye that's making
my hair look pink
it is blood it is that's a nice nice one
right there and i guess just on camera
it shows up
very pink
um i'm not allowed to wash it out of my
hair yet probably gonna look like this
for about a week
it is what it is
whatever it's fine i really want to
catch up on some of the new star field
details if you're curious about why
there's blood in my hair i just had to
have another surgery basically an
emergency surgery yesterday i'll leave a
link in the description if you want more
information in any case we got some more
news about starfield and i wanted to
talk about it because i feel like i had
um
kind of an unusual reaction to this game
where they showed us a lot of different
things
and i really liked some of those things
and others i really didn't like
and i think my immediate reaction was to
just be blown away by the amount of
content
um regardless of whether i liked or
didn't like some of those things i know
that my first reaction upon seeing
gameplay was oh this looks like fallout
and i think that i had
built it in my head
especially because i believe they're
using creation engine 2 this is on a
different engine finally
i had built it up in my head as though
it wouldn't just look like a bethesda
game like it would look
dramatically
better
than previous iterations and it's not
that it doesn't it's just so
recognizable that my first reaction was
oh
looks like fallout and then there were
definitely things that i liked i felt
like the gunplay looked massively
improved versus previous
previous fallout games um still like
obviously want to try that before
starting it but i was definitely
impressed by that um it looked a lot
more populated than previous games which
is always very exciting and is going to
keep happening the better video game
hardware gets to me as somebody who's
working in game development right now i
would say that's one of the most
exciting things about the industry to me
is
we're so limited right now by what
hardware can do um and and basically the
amount of space that we can afford so
as hardware gets better and space
becomes more affordable which is
literally like just a balance of
deciding what can and can't be fit into
the game it's not literal cost though in
a lot of cases it pertains to cost there
is absolutely a future where we have
fully populated cities
that function
very similarly to the real world and
that we have them in a skyrim or a
fallout they are like fully bustling
populated millions
um and i find that really exciting in
any case
i thought that the space combat looked
pretty neat uh
but that a lot of aspects of it looked
very similar to no man's sky and outer
worlds and i don't know i just um
i had a lot of very scattered thoughts
about it
i overall feel positively
but the one thing that i really took
away as something that blew my mind and
very much impressed me
when i first heard it that i then like
maybe two hours later was like wait i
don't want that was the thousand planets
starfield has a thousand planets you can
visit um that's too many uh
i don't want that
i would love four planets that are very
well populated and very interesting uh i
guess you know like the way that jedi
fall in order does it feel like they got
a little bit repetitive even on that
game but
you know you have a select amount of
planets that you can fly to on the ship
that you customize
and they uh
and they are very built um
the idea of having a thousand planets
either means procedural generation
or that a lot of them will be very very
boring and uninteresting and lifeless
and that
like that the amount of content that
doesn't actually impress me it almost
concerns me thankfully todd how i did
some interviews to offer some more
clarification on a whole bunch of this
stuff this is from ign so i wanted to
just update myself as well as all of you
who might have some of the same
questions that i had essentially so this
article here is about how stuff that
includes more handcrafted content than
any bethesda game alongside its
procedural galaxy uh let me make myself
smaller while we read the news wow
that's a giant ad
i made a huge amount of new information
on starfield from the xbox bethesda
showcase likely the most discussed
detail was todd howard's announcement
that the upcoming sci-fi rpg will
include 1 000 fully explorable planets
um
obviously i am somebody who tweeted
about that a lot of people tweeted about
that made comments about it um and yeah
my my initial reaction was extremely
impressed and then escalated
de-escalated quickly to concerned so
glad they spoke about it howard has now
told ign more about the game's approach
to procedural generation what it offers
and assured us that players can ignore
them in favor of a huge amount of fully
handcrafted content if they want to
which sounds great i don't think anyone
is upset about options um
speaking of ign how it addressed the
huge reaction to the news of starfield's
massively explorable space we're pretty
aware you threaded information out near
the near the end people will go what did
you just say and then they'll have a lot
of questions about how that works which
correct well howard says that the team
will offer a future deep dive into
exactly how that content was made and
how it feels in action he offered us a
glimpse into the thinking around it
centered on a single philosophy we try
to say yes as much as possible which i
feel like shows it takes them a long
time to make games saying yes can
sometimes be terrible for project
management and definitely
you know
leads to a whole lot of bugs but it also
tends to lead to innovation if every dev
studio said no we can't do that
and didn't try to do things that they
aren't sure if they can do or not we'd
end up with a lot of very boring video
games in fact i would say that that is
the most time consuming thing
about uh
game development in general from my
perspective which is pretty limited i
work on a design team is people figuring
out how to do new things for the first
time ever once somebody else has done
them and you can iterate on them that
makes it a lot faster once you've done
them before very easy
but the creation of new things that you
don't even know if you can do sometimes
you can't they have to get completely
scrapped sometimes you can and it works
out great
there's the most consuming thing uh
time-consuming thing about making a
video game and one of the biggest
challenges and i think that's a
difficult thing to convey to audiences
and maybe an important thing to mention
because people like just bring the game
out already and it's like well you don't
understand how
potentially difficult it was to just
make one part of this and how impossible
it is to tell you when that part will be
done when it's never been done before
that's an exciting part about working in
the space
okay back to the article we do a lot of
procedural generation in star fields but
i would keep in mind that we've always
done that howard explained it's a big
part of skyrim in terms of questing i
forgot about how hyped people were when
that was announced
uh and some other things we do we
generate landscape using procedural
systems so we've always kind of worked
on it the elder scrolls 2 daggerfall is
one that
is one we look at a lot in terms of game
flow
and we had been developing some
procedural technology and doing some
prototypes and it really started coming
to head with starfield and that we think
we can do this which again very exciting
well he didn't go into details howard
stressed that starfield's procedural
generation is robust enough to handle
the sheer scale of a variety required to
build 100 solar systems worth of planets
so it starts with can you even pull it
off visually you know a planet and a
planet by itself if you think about it
in a game concept just one planet is
infinitely big if you're going to do it
in some realistic fashion so once you're
dealing with scale like that and
procedural systems the difference
between say one planet that has some
variation on it and 100 planets or a
thousand planets is actually not that
big of a leap if that makes sense once
you have good systems working for that
yeah i think that makes sense if people
want to do what they're used to in our
games and follow a main quest and do the
questline you're gonna see what you'd
expect from us so
that's the thing that i found comforting
i could just not go to these extra
planets but it sounds like the main
quest
will still be very specifically crafted
to
still be handcrafted is the best way to
put that that's what it sounds like um
from from some of this extra detail how
it seems especially clear that there is
a golden path or perhaps golden freeway
might be more appropriate through
starfield
which represents the full handcrafted
bethesda rpg fans would expect and he
stresses that the team has created more
handmade content than ever before set
within its giant procedural galaxy i
should also add that we've done more
handcrafting in this game content-wise
than any game we've done we're at over
200 000 lines of dialogue so damn so we
still do a lot of handcrafting and if
people just want to do what they're used
to in our games and follow our main
quest and do the quest lines you're
gonna see what you'd kind of expect from
us but then you have this whole other
part of well i'm just gonna wander this
planet it's gonna provide some gameplay
and some random content and those kinds
of things kind of like a daggerfall
would
if you go way back again the philosophy
here is about saying yes to the player
allowing them to make detours into the
areas designers wouldn't ever have been
able to fill out and providing something
to do that even if it's not part of the
main game so i do find that to be a lot
more comforting um
and i think part of that is
if i'm going and exploring other planets
i can see myself finding one that i
really like just like you know depending
on what mood i mean i'm gonna go just
find something that looks pretty and
that's where i built my base
uh but then still go through the main
quest when i want the the mainline
bethesda-esque
game uh he continued by saying we're
also capital light you know that's what
that procedural content is so if you
look at space you know there are a lot
of ice balls in space so that was one of
our big design considerations on this
game what's fun about an ice ball and
it's okay sometimes if ice balls aren't
it is what it is we'd rather have them
have them and say yes to you hey you can
land on this here are the resources you
can survey and then you can land and
spend 10 minutes here and be like okay
now i'm going to leave and go back to
the other planet has all this other
content on it and i'm going to follow
this questline i think that makes sense
and kind of confirms that some of them
will probably be kind of boring that's
okay
i don't need a thousand planets in my
life i don't want them so we're pretty
careful about saying here's where the
funny is here's this kind of content but
still say yes to the player and you want
to go land on that weird planet check it
out and build an outpost and live your
life there and watch the sunset because
you like the view of the moon set go for
it we love that stuff which is kind of
what i'm saying is my plan
um so that's the update on that which i
found to be
comforting i guess um yeah i wonder how
many people will actually explore a
thousand planets and i guess just yeah
as long as some of the planets still
feel like they're completely handcrafted
that seems like a win uh so we do have a
couple more uh news pieces to catch up
on from this this massive interview that
they
got which is awesome shout out to joe
scrubbles
uh todd house who's confirmed to ign the
fallout 5 will be bethesda game studios
next game after the elder scrolls 6
which itself will follow on from 2023
star field all of that makes sense that
we get starfield elder scrolls fallout
but these games are going to be so far
away
so yes elder scrolls six is in
pre-production and you know we're going
to be doing fallout 5 after that so
sleep's pretty full going forward for a
while we have some other projects that
we look at from time to time as well
howard has told ign previously that
studio has an idea for fallout 5 in
place saying fallout's really part about
dna here we've worked with other
developers from time to time i can't say
what's gonna happen
what why would you even mention that
why would you
this just broke me because my brain went
obsidian
why would you even mention that if not
to tease obsidian who
i believe are currently working on four
projects three of them we know of
which is the game i'm forgetting the
name of the new one that was announced
it looks awesome
grounded
about
i think they're working on four and i
don't know what the fourth is i'm
getting myself too excited that's stupid
uh how it hadn't confirmed it would
definitely be on the way after the elder
scrolls six but of course it was um i
want to see if there are any years in
here
doesn't look like it but these games
aren't going to be out for a really long
time
so we also got some news about
starfield's main quest being about 20
bigger than previous bethesda games
around 30 to 48 hours long which i think
i like this says
starfield's main quest is about 20
bigger than previous bethesda games such
as skyrim and fallout 4. with todd
howard saying that
means it should take around 30 to 40
hours to complete without stepping away
to do side content speaking to ign after
the gameplay reveal at the xbox but
there's a showcase but there's a veteran
and starfield director todd howard said
the game's main story is longer than
normal due to the sheer number of quests
this one's ending up a bit longer than
our previous game so we may tune that
some still he said uh it also says
howard believes the modding community
will keep starfield fresh for a long
time even on top of dlc expansions
bethesda will inevitably create which is
definitely exciting there's also some
info here about starfield having four
main cities uh and new atlantis is
bethesda's biggest city that they've
ever made toward howard said new
atlantis capital city of the united
colonies is not just the base in this
game but bigger than anything in skyrim
fallout 4 or any of the developers
previous games i wonder how they define
biggest
they did say it has all the services you
would expect and you can work on your
ship there
the factions touch that but that's also
the headquarters for the constellation
which is a faction that you join that is
the last group of space explorers
explorers sorry kind of like nasa meets
indiana jones meets the league of
extraordinary gentlemen
howard explained that starfield's main
quest which he also said be longer will
mostly take place in partnership with
constellation and thus through new
atlanta so you probably spend a lot of
time there the city will feature much
more than that of course as plenty of
sidequests will also start and take
place there as the capital city of the
united colonies faction it will
seemingly also serve as a starting point
for that questline too so the last two
tidbits are about flying
uh starfield doesn't let you fly
seamlessly from space to planet that's
really just not that important and
that's obviously a big distinction from
no man's sky also apparently people in
the community are getting upset that
this game is being compared to no man's
sky what are you talking about of course
it is
um it's like a joke to say that they're
not
similar and games being similar is okay
no man's sky rules so todd howard said
that starfield won't allow you to
seamlessly fly from space to its one
thousand explorable planet saying the
feature is really just not that
important to the player to justify the
engineering work involved
it is like making its own game i suppose
howard explained that while the
philosophy was key to things like
procedurally generic the philosophy of
saying yes to the player sorry was key
to things like procedurally generating
the 100 sold systems the team did say no
to ideas that weren't deemed as crucial
to the experience people have asked can
you fly the ship straight down to the
planet no we decided early in the
project that on surface is one reality
and then when you're in space it's
another reality so it'll be a loading
screen
a cinematic
not sure
exactly how it'll work
the last one is about starfield space
combat
which again i think my first reaction to
was that it looked really cool i think
especially because i didn't expect it to
exist for whatever reason it's
definitely different anything that
bethesda's ever done before um and yeah
apparently it's inspired by ftl and mech
warrior and you can steal ships that you
bought which is super exciting
speaking ign following the xbox bethesda
game showcase howard said there's been a
lot of space sims that we're fans of and
space shooters from the 90s but the team
wanted starfield to feel like something
unique deploying different amounts of
power to different ship subsystems for
example was influenced by 2012 spaceship
simulation game ftl which by the way
should absolutely play ftl is very hard
but it is awesome
in it players would regularly have to
make critical decisions such as choosing
between powering their engines to try
and escape a fight
or their weapons to try and win it
your ship has various power systems
there's a little bit of ftl in there in
terms of putting how much power into
three different weapon systems how it
said which actually sounds like it's
kind of similar to
star wars squadrons you had like
different uh power modes
that you would put energy into uh howard
said then your engines and shields and
grab drive is what lets you jump so it's
gonna be fast travel or something and
sort of get out of some situations that
you have to put power to for its take on
dogfighting bethesda targeted a slower
pace and how it had an unlikely
inspiration for that one of the games i
love that we sort of look at for pace is
mechwarrior believe it or not it's
probably a little bit slower but in
terms of systems and power and being
able to line things up it's a little bit
faster than that
but you know what i mean as opposed to a
twitchy dogfighter starfield space
combat also includes other less directly
violent elements we also have some other
systems that we'll show later that you
can add to your ship that adds some more
interesting gameplay uh howard said
before going onto a list of number a
number of other space-based activities
including hijacking other ships you can
do that in space
that's cool it's not just dogfighting
like the ship stuff includes you can see
it in the video you can dock with other
ships you can disable them you can dock
you can board it that is cool i feel
like maybe i missed that or forgot about
it i forgot to stop all the time there's
actually some quests that involve that
you can steal the ship there's dialogue
in space there's star stations you can
visit there's smuggling all the things
that we would want and we'll be showing
some more of that later
but it's a good chunk of gameplay that
we think is really fun when it comes to
playing this kind of sci-fi game it
definitely sounds fun
um so i think that's everything that i
wanted to catch up on i wanted to catch
up on it so i thought that some of you
would maybe also want to catch up on it
uh
yeah definitely very interested in some
of the stuff starfield is doing
while also trying to ground myself at
this point to realize that it is
probably going to be very similar
to the outer world or to any other
bethesda
rpg more so than i feel like i had
originally suspected for whatever reason
um and that's okay
they've always been great games probably
got a lot of bugs
and that's also okay
sometimes they're funny sometimes they
break the video game but it's not great
uh that is it for me today everyone i'll
see you guys next time